madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
dams et messieurs
c'est avec une profonde tristesse que
nous avons appris
c'était le 7 décembre dernier la
disparition de notre collègue catherine
fournier sénatrice du pas-de-calais
elle nous a quittés à l'âge de 66 ans à
l'issue d'une longue et cruelle maladie
contre laquelle il s'est battu avec un
courage incroyable
jusqu'au bout elle a continué à
s'intéresser aux travaux de notre
assemblée je me souviens personnellement
avoir encore échanger avec elles à ce
sujet on s'est tous derniers jours
j'étais présent à fretin ses obsèques ce
fut une émouvante cérémonie d'adieu à
laquelle assistaient de nombreux élus et
habitants
de sa chère ville et du pas de calais
le don de soi et l'amour du prochain ont
sans cesse guider la vie de catherine
fournier
né à boulogne sur mer elle a grandi près
de calais à fretin communes dont son
père que je salue ici rld et aux chats
fut longtemps maire
si sans doute dans cet environnement
familial au cours des premières années
de sa vie que se forge à sa vocation
pour le service de l'intérêt général
sa passion pour l'engagement public et
politique
après un diplôme universitaire de
gestion des entreprises et des
administrations
obtenu à lille
catherine fournier y fit ses débuts
professionnels dans le secteur des
assurances
mais dès
1988 à l'âge de 33 ans elle était de
retour à fretin où elle fonda une
entreprise gérant une résidence
hôtelière sous forme pavillonnaire elle
fut longtemps chef d'entreprise et
illustra dans ses fonctions déjà
l'engagement en contribuant par exemple
à travers l'édification de motel à loger
des ouvriers et leurs familles c'était
la construction alors du tunnel sous la
manche
mais ce don de soi car il fournit en
apporte à surtout le témoignage de plus
éloquent dans l'exercice de ses
différents mandats et singulièrement son
mandat de maire
sept ans après son retour à fretin élus
la fierté de succéder à son père à la
mairie
brillamment réélu à trois reprises par
la suite avec toujours de très beaux
scores
premier tour 2008 90%
et d'aller rester maire pendant 22 ans
elle y renoncera en 2017 après son
élection au sénat pour se mettre en
conformité avec la législation sur le
cumul des mandats pendant plus de deux
décennies elle mis toute son énergie et
sa générosité au service des habitants
de fretin elle devra beau avec beaucoup
d'efficacité pour l'emploi et
l'aménagement du territoire elle
s'investit à fond dans le dossier de la
gare internationale de calais fréthun
point d'entrée du tunnel sous la manche
grâce à son action la ville s'est
métamorphosé en se développant autour
cette gare tgv international et des
installations d'eurotunnel
profond takraw rendre en chine et dans
sa commune catherine fournier l'était
aussi à son département et à sa région
et du conseillère général du pas de
calais de 2006 à 2008 puis conseillère
régionale à partir de 2015
aux côtés de xavier bertrand elle
contribue au dynamisme économique de la
région elle exerça en outre
d'importantes responsabilités
dans les intercommunalités vice
présidente de la communauté de communes
du sud ouest du calaisis puis
vice-président de l'agglomération de
grand kallé terre et mer
catherine fournier
je suis pas seulement une élue locale
exemplaires elle sut aussi une grande
sénatrice son entrée au sénat en
septembre 2010 sept marquera sa vie
politique
après avoir sillonné le pas de calais au
cours de la campagne pour les élections
sénatoriales alors de mairie en mairie
aux côtés de jean françois rapin et du
regretté philippe rapeneau elle a
défendu avec passion au sein de notre
assemblée sa commune le calaisis son
département le pas de calais
dès son arrivée nous avons apprécié
cette femme souvenez-vous souriante
chaleureuse dont les premières
interventions dans l'hémicycle sur
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
elle adhéra
au groupe de la vie politique sa
commission des affaires sociales
particulièrement assidus aux réunions de
commissions elle se plonge a très
rapidement dans les travaux législatifs
et fut nommé dès juin
2018 co-rapporteur de l'importer un
projet de loi pour la liberté
lionel sur le volet relatif à
l'information professionnelle en octobre
de la même année elle devint président
de la commission spéciale sur le projet
de loi relatifs à la croissance et à la
transformation des entreprises elle
exerça cette lourde responsabilité
avec pragmatisme et engagement menant à
bien dans des délais brefs l'examen d'un
texte fleuve et dix ans le quelque peu
hétéroclite qui a donné lieu à près de
360 auditions et débauché sur la loi
dite pacte riche
de plus de 200 articles par sa maîtrise
des sujets qui étaient souvent des
sujets techniques pas son sens du
dialogue elle sut immédiatement suscité
l'estimé et le respect de ses collègues
et j'ai le souvenir de ses interventions
en conférence des présidents
en 2020 il participa à la commission
spéciale sur le projet loi
d'accélération et de simplification de
l'action publique
elle s'applique à également dans les
travaux de contrôle et d'évaluation des
politiques publiques
avec deux de ses collègues membres de la
commission des affaires sociales michel
forissier et frédérique puissat elle fit
l'auteur d'un rapport d'information
rapport remarqué par sa grande qualité
sur le droit social applicable aux
travailleurs des plateformes elle les a
formulés d'intéressantes propositions
pour améliorer la protection sociale de
ces travailleurs qui se trouvent souvent
dans des situations
particulièrement précaire s'est aussi
mobilisé sur le sujet de la pénurie de
médicaments l'un des effets de la crise
sanitaire plaidant alors pour une
mutualisation européenne
notamment de l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est un autre beaucoup investi au sein
de la délégation aux entreprises
à la suite du renouvellement de 2020
catherine fournier
rejoignez la commission des affaires
économiques et la commission des
affaires européennes dont les présidents
sophie primas et jean françois rapin
peuvent moynier de la finesse de ses
analyses et de sa bonne connaissance des
dossiers économiques et sociaux
lors des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
elle marquait pugnacité notamment sur
les dossiers de d'apprentissage mais
aussi de l'impact la pêche industrielle
sur l'écosystème ou encore sur le sujet
du break site
catherine fournier a toujours eu à coeur
de défendre son territoire elle s'est
battu avec acharnement pour que soit
conservé les arrêts de l'eurostar à
fréthun tout comme elle s'est battue
pour les droits des pêcheurs français
lors des négociations du break site
sa dernière intervention dans notre
musique c'était il ya un peu plus d'un
an
fut pour défendre la mise en place d'un
statut adapté à la spécificité
de la liaison fixe transmanche
à l'instar de celui des ports et des
aérodromes
au fond à ne céder rien
je repense à cette phrase du général de
gaulle
soyons fermes pure et fidèle au bout de
nos peines il y a la plus grande gloire
du monde celle des femmes et des hommes
qui n'ont pas cédé
car il fournit l a jamais cédé et
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout de sa vie
toute sa vie elle aura conservé cette
ténacité cette droiture
bien sûr passionné par la vie publique
et politique mais aussi par les voyages
la musique c'était de l'avis de tous
ceux qui l'ont connu une femme
compétente courageuse persévérant mais
aussi profondément bienveillante
généreuse et charismatique voyez vous le
dira à cet instant dans cet hémicycle
la voix encore ici là en face face de
moi
une sénatrice
chaleureuse une élue de proximité
au fond une véritable humaniste qui
avait une profonde empathie
pour les autres
à ses anciens collègues des commissions
des affaires sociales des affaires
économiques zafir européenne ses amis du
groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président et vous valérie
létard qui m'avaient accompagné
au dernier jour de cette rencontre que
nous avions dans l'église de fréthun
j'exprime eu une fois encore notre
sympathie attristée à son père
rené ancien maire de fréthun à son époux
jean claude ses enfants antoine et anna
sa soeur michelle
à ses proches ainsi qu'à toutes celles
et tous ceux qui l'ont accompagné tout
au long de sa vie et on partageait ses
engagements souhaite redire à part que
le sénat a pris et continue à prendre à
leur deuil votre peine est aussi la
nôtre c'est vrai nous avions loué avec
elle ses liens d'estimé et d'amitié qui
n'ait cédé dès la première rencontre
elle restera présente dans nos mémoires